la journaliste Marina
os vianicova célèbre pour avoir dénoncé
l'offensive russe en Ukraine pendant un
journal d'information de la télévision
d'État sort un livre autobiographique
elle avait brandi en direct à la
télévision russe une pancarte now non à
la guerre l'ouvrage paraît ce vendredi
en Allemagne ce même jour elle a donné
une conférence de presse à Paris dans
les locaux de RSF Reporters sans
frontières pour raconter sa fuite de
Russie avec sa fille grâce à RSF il y a
quatre mois quand elle était assignée à
résidence on l'écoute
protester dans la Russie actuelle est
impossible à peine on lève la tête
aussitôt notre vie est complètement
détruite c'est un véritable état
totalitaire ça ressemble à l'époque de
Staline le Kremlin utilise la répression
politique et la psychiatrie punitive
on retrouve Christophe de Loire
secrétaire général de RSF reporters Sans
Frontières merci d'être avec nous quels
ont été tout d'abord ses principaux
messages lors de cette conférence de
presse
le message c'était le message que il
faut lutter contre la propagande c'est
ce que le 14 mars dernier Marina of
scencova a fait en brandissant cette
pancarte que vous évoquiez cet appareil
de propagande il est faramineux cet
appareil de propagande à la solde du
Kremlin il est malheureusement efficace
mais il est possible de lutter contre
lui par différents moyens c'est ce qu'a
fait Marina of scenicova et ce que nous
avons raconté aujourd'hui c'est c'est
cette fuite puisqu'elle était assignée à
résidence elle avait un bracelet
électronique elle était menacée de 10
ans de prison son procès devait avoir
lieu le 9 octobre 2022
et au mois de septembre un peu avant
elle nous a appelé et elle a dit est-ce
que reporters Sans Frontières peut
m'aider et nous lui avons répondu par
positivement donc elle est
particulièrement courageuse comment
elle a été exfiltrée si vous pouvez nous
en dire quelque chose
alors évidemment une pardonbre dans
cette histoire pour protéger des gens
pour protéger
la capacité de futur moscovites le cas
échéant à fuir mais ce que je peux vous
raconter c'est que elle a réussi à se
séparer de son bracelet électronique en
le coupant elle était partie avec une
pince coupante et elle a eu des grandes
difficultés à franchir une frontière
parce que malheureusement c'était le
septième véhicule qu'elle utilisait il
s'est embourbé elle a dû quitter le
véhicule à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière marcher sous un ciel étoilé
pour se repérer parce que le réseau
téléphonique ne passait pas elle avait
des valises il lui avait été conseillé
de prendre plutôt des sacs à dos mais
elle elle avait des valises et donc
ça a été une épreuve physique
extrêmement dur elle a failli craquer
elle n'a pas craqué et elle a pu accéder
au territoire européen en octobre et
c'est une première pour un SF
d'exfiltrer des journalistes menacés
dans des régimes autoritaires ou des
dictatures
nous reporters nous nous avons des
actions publiques nous avons des actions
d'influence auprès des Pouvoirs nous
avons des actions très concrètes nous
avons créé des centres pour les
journalistes Ukrainiens à le vif à Kiev
nous luttons contre la censure nous
avons débloqué la censure de médias
russe qui sont désormais accessibles au
public russe mais nous avons aussi des
actions effectivement visant à aider des
journalistes nous avons aidé 150
journalistes sur le plan administratif
pour pouvoir quitter Moscou et trouver
la liberté sur le territoire européen et
pouvoir continuer leurs activités au
moment des évacuations d'Afghanistan
nous avons travaillé à des opérations
très concrètes de journalistes afghan
face au pouvoir des talibans après la
prise de pouvoir acabul c'est ce type
d'opération discrète mais efficace que
nous avons réédité pour en savoir plus
sur éventuellement ce qui se passe en
Russie actuellement est-ce que beaucoup
de Russes pensent comme elles
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a une
opposition silencieuse qui n'arrive pas
à s'exprimer mais qui reste quand même
importante en Russie
en fait c'est le propre des régimes
despotiques qu'on a du mal à savoir et
eux-mêmes ont du mal à savoir ce que
pense réellement la population c'est à
dire la première vue la propagande elle
est extrêmement efficace lorsque des
personnes sont interrogées sur la Place
Rouge elle clament leur foi en Vladimir
Poutine après ce que les Russes ont au
fond du cerveau de leur neurones ça
malheureusement c'est extrêmement
difficile à dire alors peut-être que
heureusement c'est très difficile à dire
ce que ça fait partie de la fragilité
des pouvoirs thématique mal nommé les
choses c'est ajouter aux malheurs du
monde disait Camus et elle a osé appeler
la chose par son nom no work est-ce
qu'elle a eu des soutiens de collègues
journalistes à ce moment-là elle a
également montré en faisant en faisant
ainsi que la télévision russe d'État
était bâillonnée
c'est une femme assez seule un acte de
bravoure comme celui-là ça isole d'une
certaine manière parce que même si
beaucoup de Russes vont déposer des
fleurs ont des actes de résistance
parfois discrets mais déposer des fleurs
en Russie aujourd'hui c'est considéré
comme un acte de résistance où le fait
sous surveillance policière et risquer
des arrestations elles évidemment ça lui
a pas fait que des amis mais elle a eu
le courage de le faire de le rééditer
parce qu'elle a continué après un bref
séjour en Europe au printemps elle était
retournée à Moscou et là sur le quai
Sainte-Catherine face au Kremlin elle a
fait une action en faveur des enfin en
faveur en hommage aux enfants Ukrainiens
qui avaient été tués dont elle a apporté
le nombre officiel selon l'ONU d'enfants
Ukrainiens qui avaient été tués bref
c'est une femme qui désormais de la
constance dans son engagement est-ce
qu'on sait comment est perçu la
conscription par les Russes
alors moi je ne suis pas le meilleur
spécialiste de la question
nous nous travaillons sur la liberté de
la presse est-ce que je peux dire
aujourd'hui s'agissant de la Russie
c'est que c'est un pays où 37
journalistes ont été tués depuis
l'accession au pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine il y en a aujourd'hui à peu près
19 enfin au moins 19 journalistes
détenus en Russie surtout du fait de la
loi contre les fausses informations qui
punit 15 ans de prison ceux qui au font
diraient la vérité parce que c'est
vraiment un régime juridique kafkaïen un
régime d'oppression il y a 200 médias
qui sont qualifiés d'agents de
l'étranger ce qui emporte des
conséquences juridiques très négatives
et des centaines de journalistes qui ont
été contraints à l'exil donc savoir
exactement ce que pense la population
russe sur la conscription comme sur
d'autres sujets encore une fois c'est
difficile c'est la même chose pour la
guerre ou une opération spéciale
j'imagine dernière question est-ce
qu'elle a dit pendant pendant cette
conférence de presse comment elle
envisage elle la fin de la guerre
elle espère évidemment que cette guerre
prendra fin au plus vite elle a évoqué
des hypothèses
que se passera-t-il en Russie si le
régime de Vladimir Poutine venait à
tomber est-ce que ce serait un autre
forme de pouvoir despotique est-ce qu'il
y aurait une forme de guerre civile ça
c'est évidemment très difficile à dire
moi je ne vais pas me donner à
ces prédictions mais en tout cas
ce qu'elle a dit c'est que la Russie
doit perdre cette guerre sinon ce sera
un drame pour les Russes à long terme
évidemment pour l'ensemble des autres
pays merci beaucoup Christophe Deloire
d'avoir été avec nous sur France 24
merci à vous une interview réalisée
également grâce à l'aide de Karim akik